foreign
who am I rooting for this year the 95th
Oscars it's an easy choice for me
everything everywhere all at once like I
said
it's not most people speak this film was
Transcendent it takes the biggest Wings
takes the biggest risks it's Bonkers but
it still has a heart to it the
fablements is my favorite 95th Oscar
nominated movie how'd you make it look
like the guns were really firing it
encapsulates the movie Magic we all feel
and the lights begin to dim and we go
somewhere we have been before the best
picture nominated film I'm rooting for
is Elvis and I might be a little biased
I left the theater and I felt like I was
on another planet
now is the time because it is
I'm rooting for Avatar I'm saving my
life just seeing it in the theaters took
me to a different dimension the
cinematography the storyline the visuals
were stunning The Best Picture film that
I am rooting for is the Banshees of Anna
Sheeran it's a film that I'm really
personally involved the scenery was
Haunting beautiful and Colin Farrell's
performance was brilliant she stopped
running away from me he's like some fool
of a Moody School child Top Gun
Mavericks should win best picture
because it really revitalized the
theater experience that brought
everything to the table that you would
think that Top Gun sequel would bring
and then more women talking should get
some Oscar love this year who may need
to protect ourselves I haven't gotten
nervous in a movie in a long time here
is why triangle of sadness deserves to
win best picture at the Oscars it's
always yes sir yes ma'am great plot
original takes awesome characters this
year I'm running for all quite on the
Western Front
it's one of the most terrorizing films
I've ever seen yet one of the most
beautiful
[Music]